one of the things about Brooklyn
nine-nine is that you get to learn a lot
of action moves yes
you know people show you these cool fun
move cop stuff yeah and last time you
were here you showed us I think how to
slide as long live while shooting while
shooting a miling at the same time we
have a moment from that yeah I'm just
curious like that was such a good one if
they taught you any new one since then
they have you know that was right when
the show started and them so I picked up
a lot of new stuff and I if you guys
don't mind I'll do another one yeah this
is cool yeah this is great
this is a known freak out this is fake
fake gun Brian okay so what's the
scenario here you're yeah like I'm like
going after a perp and then I do this
move okay ready yeah here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
I was incredible job right nicely done
so you know just like cop stuff sure you
gained a lot of weight the minute you
yeah pounded like 340s donut what
happened got lit on fire came back out
here and finish out it burned the fat
right off yeah that was great
yeah just coming out of your pocket yeah
for no reason
season four a Brooklyn Duck nothing's
premieres tomorrow night at 8:00 on Fox
and storks is in theaters on Friday
[Applause]
talk about a hot pocket
the food television yeah yeah I'm
enjoying this most of all whatever you
can group it all helicopter spin is
really on fire
you